all right I want to talk about irony and
because a lot of your videos deal with
your first videos about David Foster
Wallace the problem with irony but then
a lot of your videos are also about like
Rick and Morty Simpsons South Park all
these shows Bojack horseman that are
largely the cowgirl I think they come
from cynicism irony all that all that
stuff how do you think about that and do
you think that there's any scaffold of
meaning that they're missing or do you
think that what do you think about these
shows it's a really really hard question
because even once you're teaching from
that mode of discourse like once you're
teaching from Arne and you are using it
to pull back the veil on things and say
this is not how it seems kind of right
it's hard to escape that it's hard to go
back and say now I'm only gonna talk
about this from this one level and and
be confident and sincere about that and
I'm not going to talk about the
potential underlayer that subverts that
yeah right it's a sword that cuts both
ways
it cuts both ways I mean I can't make
the point any better than Wallace did
however many years ago which was just
like once everything is saturated with
that where do you go from there like
once you've once you've ironically
deconstructed everything then what like
like and you know we talked about this
just at lunch which was that like you
can see these hyper sincere figures
coming into the mainstream because there
are a lot of people who are lost because
everything in their generation has just
been so take
in a part to the point where they're
like what should i what should I believe
yeah and then someone comes along and
says here I have one set of beliefs for
you and and and and I'm going to speak
charismatic Allah and I have these ideas
that are appealing and here here's your
framework and then you see those people
just flying up and one of the big
problems with irony is you it's a great
way to you know show things for what
they are in some respects but again it
doesn't lead you necessarily to an
answer which is a big problem with irony
yeah in terms of the shows that you
mentioned though one of the things about
them as I think they know that like
these these writers know the about this
problem and so a lot of them have tried
to add in elements of the opposite of
like how do we sincerity at the end of
the irony right now and like exactly
which has been called a lot of things
yeah it gets most popularly it's been
called meta modernism right it's very
hard to define easily but essentially
like for example Bojack horseman like
he's so well trained in the cynicism of
the v like just like the audience and
the way to pass through that is
essentially to have him say something
ironic or cynical and then have the
opposite be true in the narrative and
and I think Raphael bob-waksberg is a
genius when it comes to this which is
sort of like I'm gonna take something
that everybody is so ironic and cynical
about and then show that it it's not
necessarily the be-all end-all truth
about the matter and that it can also go
the other direction a lot of the
time yeah and so I think a lot of a lot
of writers know this problem they've
been working on it I think one of the
big problems remains is that irony makes
the viewer feel smarter than they are
it's true it's just a fact is like ha ha
ha I'm in on the joke so and and that
keeps someone attached to it right and
and so when they when someone watches
John Stewart and he makes an ironic
comment this is old now he's not on TV
well like when they feel like they're in
on the joke boom you activated the
tribal senses that person is ready to
keep listening to them being
holier-than-thou ironic above the other
person it remains a problem in culture I
don't think it's as bad as it was when
Wallace was talking about it at least I
don't think so like I think there's so
many other outlets now with the internet
that you don't have to be stuck there
sure I was definitely stuck there which
is why he's so influential on me is like
I thought it was the be-all end-all I
was raised on Jon Stewart and I was
raised on simply treating things as
ironic constantly and then all of a
sudden
reading Wallace was like it was almost
like a flip switched in my brain a
switch flipped flipped the words yeah in
my brain and and all of a sudden I was
like oh my gosh like a weight has been
lifted off my shoulders you know what I
mean yeah yeah it's amazing that that
writer can do that for you but they can
[Music]